and postdocs starting off with Dennis I
worked really closely with throughout my
PhD excited to see what you've been up
to
take it away okay thank you so um
yeah in the schedule it says that it is
a student section although I'm not a
student anymore now I wish I was a
student
okay so hopefully the million of this
title would be clear by the end of the
presentation
let me first start by saying happy
Birthday Tony
and I actually
met Tony for the first time when I was
an undergraduate student at U of T in
2007. and when I Was preparing the
slides I wanted to recall what was the
course that I was taking so I went to
Tony's homepage
and I didn't find that chorus listed
there so I decided to go over my email
and I found actually some email exchange
that I had
so uh you see in December 2007 I sent
Tony an email asking me if the final
marks are already available
so uh her response was uh they're not
ready yet but hopefully soon
so I waited a few days sent a follow-up
message
when she responded
and there were a few other
exchanges after that so now that I'm a
professor myself I realized that I was a
very annoying student
did you ever find out you're great oh
yes
so uh
it was a plus
okay so
that was the CSCO 438 course and my
experience as a student in that course
was that whenever I would come to a
lecture and Tony would explain the
difficult topics everything was super
clear
okay I left the lecture every time
uh completely sure that I understood 100
percent
but then when I tried to solve an
assignment it turned out that I didn't
understand anything
and I tried to reflect on why that is
the case and essentially I think that
this is a sign of Tony being a true
professional and this is because
if you think about sports or any other
discipline a true professional actually
makes things look very easy when they do
it even if these things are very
complicated
and yeah so that was my experience and
Tony is of course very accomplished as
well no but in my mind I think that
um
there is an even bigger accomplishment
and that is Tony is very kind person and
repair it down to earth and it's very
hard to stay kind and down to earth when
you become very accomplished and famous
so that's very good and I later got a
chance to work with the Tony closely in
my postdoc
and that's resulted in a couple of
Publications on proof complexity and I
worked closely with Tony and now and
Robert during this time
so since then I've been working actually
on a different topic
I've been interested in online
algorithms
and I've done several projects so on
different Online problems such as
Dynamic beam packing online bipartite
matching
online coloring online dominating set
and I'm co-writing a book on online
algorithms so with Alan border
please don't ask me when the book is
going to come out
in problem
okay so when I was thinking um
what can I present to this audience here
I wanted to say something that would be
of interest to the audience and a lot of
people here are interested in proof
complexity and satisfiability
so and the the workshop
um that this
event is
attached to
also talks about practical input
instances so this is something that I
wanted to do here and in particular Give
an example how
uh online practical or how practical
instances really
Revitalize the area of online bipartite
match and based on that idea I wanted to
propose an online or a random model for
generating input instances for
satisfiability
this is a little bit experimental on my
part because
I'm not an expert in that area and I'm
not 100 sure if that model has been
cited or not a quick search didn't
reveal it but if it has been studied you
can tell me I'd be very interested and
if it hasn't been stated I think there
are many research questions
foreign
so next I'll talk a little bit about
online bipartite match and to kind of
provide the motivation for the input
model
so in the online bipartite mentioned
one side of the graph is offline so it's
given to the algorithm in advance and
the vertices on another side arrive
online so when the vertex arrives we
learn all its neighbors and we need to
decide which of the edges we're going to
include in the match and that decision
is irrevocable
and here for instance you can take this
Edge then the next vertex arrives maybe
you take this Edge the next vertex
arrives you cannot take the top Edge
anymore it needs to be a valid matching
um but you also don't have to take any
Edge if you
so you can not decide not to match that
vertex
so for this vertex you do this and so on
okay so uh
then the measure of how well the
solution is is the competitive ratio
which is the
analogous to approximation ratio
so
um
paper that introduced online bipartite
match and was carp with Iranian with
Iranian in 1990. and it cited this
problem in the adversarial input model
and
this is a seminal paper and what is
great about this paper is that it
introduces the problem and solves the
problem
not much to say after that so for a
deterministic algorithms they show a
tight competitive ratio of a half and
for randomized algorithm there is a type
competitive ratio of 1 minus one over e
0.63
now for for a while this problem
didn't see a lot of
work until in 2009 there was a
Resurgence of Interest
I felt when the towel introduced this
non-id model and they show how in the
non-id model we can actually do better
than the adversarial
and there was a whole sequence of papers
and this is still an active area of
research
so what is this known ID and why did it
lead to such an interest
so in the non-id input model
there is a type graph
of based on which an actual realization
graph is generated
and in this type graph
on one side of the type graph we have
online types of vertices and we have a
probability distribution on the types of
vertices
and then the actual realization graph is
constructed by sampling a bunch of
vertices
ID from this distribution
and the right in the draft pathway
and the online algorithm is assumed to
know the type graph in advance but
realization graph it doesn't know in
advance
okay so one of the applications of this
idea is to online advertising
essentially
consider an online ad platform which
we'll call G here for no specific
reasons
so
it happens when you go on g type
something and
search results show up on the side there
is a banner space and behind the scenes
there is an a delivery service Ryan
and um
so G has a database of advertisers and
each Advertiser might have a limit on
the number of times and that is
displayed a user clicks on a website and
then that delivery service
needs to decide which Advertiser to
display
to match to the user
so Jay actually knows user you better
but the user knows themselves so they
can do it quite a question plan and they
know the advertisers that are compatible
with the user so
uh G has this historical frequency data
on how often users of a certain type
arrive so they can actually learn the
type graph associated with this problem
and then a user could be an actual
realization graph input that they
assumed arrives I.E
so
G wants to maximize the number of heads
shown revenue and things like that so
the underlying can be notorial problem
is this bipartite mention problem with
the known type graph
and
this way of generating input randomly
for bipartite Imagine is actually one of
the main reasons for why this
Resurgence of interest in bipartite
Imagine happen because the input is just
the input model is so good
but people do it practice
so there are other random input models
possible for this problem unknown ID
entity
the type graph is not known to
um to the algorithm random order input
model for sun arrivals
but it is also possible to extend it to
allow dependencies between subsequent
samples so for instance I want to also
introduce Markov chain model on the tax
which will
control
which user is more likely which user
type is more likely to adhere after you
have seen something
and so this allows to capture the
dependence in the end of this skill is
easier to learn it from the frequency
data
so it is quite General and it can
simulate normal ID and Mania so it leads
to many interesting research questions
and particularly it's possible to study
these questions for different classes of
Markov chains
so this is wide open and currently I
have a PhD student who is working on
this club
right so
what about such as availability what can
we do here well one of the most popular
ways of generating random instances is a
random case
so I'm going to State it in terms of
rejection sampling so to create a new
Clause we sample K variables ID we
negate each variable with probability
half independently and if the Clause
trivializes so there is a repeated
variable we reject it and try again
so this is a popular model but it does
not actually attach to Industrial
instances and in fact it is one of the
challenges that is stated to develop
a random input model which would allow
one to capture industrial instances
there there are several attempts at
doing this
and for instance two random input models
that I was able to find
a literature search is balance set where
you incorporate and the generation
process the constraint that the literal
needs to appear approximately the same
number of clauses and scale three sets
were what you want to achieve is that
variable occurrence distribution should
follow a power law
so
what is the input model that I suggest
to
consider for research question is Markov
chain input model so here we would be
given a Markov chain on the state space
which contains all your variables and
their negations and to generate the
Clause you try a walk-off case X if you
get a valid Clause do you keep it
otherwise you reject it and try again
and you can start generating the next
Clause where the previous one laptop
so as I mentioned I'm not 100 sure if
this appeared in research literature or
not before so there was a big group of
experts here if someone can have seen it
before I would be interested in hearing
about that uh but I didn't find this
model here
but
um
in particular this model can simulate
random case set if you take the Markov
chain to be just a random walk on the
complete directed graph but it's
interesting to study this more
generalized version both online and
offline
in fact here are some research questions
that I want to leave with
so can this Markov chain input model
actually capture industrial instances
that would require some kind of
empirical evaluation
other natural classes of Markov chains
for which Max set can be solved
optimally
I is there always a satisfiability
threshold and is it possible to express
satisfability threshold in terms of some
Markov chain parameters that would be I
think really interesting to do
all right so this is all I have uh thank
you
[Applause]
uh thanks Dennis that was really cool
um any questions
oh uh here
um
here I would say that
you are given um
and you know the way that your formula
is generated it comes from this market
chain of this cross
but then the way that the formula is
presented online it could be in one of
those input models from your paper with
Nicholas right so if you assume that the
formula was already generated and then
it's just presented online
yeah
uh any other questions do you have any
specific
so uh for the Mansion problem I think uh
right now my students is looking at
simple examples we we actually looked at
some constant size Mark exchange just to
see how it behaves but now uh for
instance he's looking at a very simple
Markov chain where at each state you
have a half probability of stand in that
state or a half probability transition
to the next stage
so even for this simple example at least
in the case of match and it's not
immediate but for satisfiability it
would need to be
all right let's thank Dennis again
[Applause]
all right take it away Eva
[Laughter]
same time
yeah so I was thinking what I should
talk about that's why I went to
inspiration foreign
towards the end of my PhD
you know
so we had a kind of stuff to do at the
end to give some feedback and I was
complaining hey Tony
so you never gave me any any big project
to work on like all of these other
people who
I once have aspired to be like
so what did you say did you remember
what would you say now
we're doing
it
exactly what you said back then
questions
so Tony said look we were doing great I
didn't want to interfere like there's no
need to uh to change anything if don't
don't fix it if they are broken right
so I can add it to the list of the
things that uh I should have learned
from Tony but I never have
yeah so
let's see
how do you do research so that's a few
things that you know reflecting back
I may be like the polar opposite I don't
do any of these things and that maybe
that's why uh I'm not as successful so
let's say one thing so how do you uh how
do you choose what to work on
okay so one thing that you can do is uh
you can choose a paper that you saw
somewhere and you think it's cool it's
maybe relevant is interesting
and just go on and read it very
carefully
so in my case it was a staple of Aaron
Patel on monitoring switching Networks
in other cases one might assume that
there was McKenzie paper got read and a
new area was being opened I don't know
the history but that will make sense
and maybe at that point I want to give a
little anecdote so I know I'm not
supposed to talk too much about myself
but um
because you know it's not mine yeah
but
so when I was in China there were all
these people doing great things
right so deep learning uh break was very
happening literally the next morning
over yeah
and others
the Clinton
all this co-working lifting was done you
know by my very same advisor and by my
uh you know roommate uh Mika yeah so all
these things were happening in parallel
to me and I was doing my own thing
so I'm not sure what's the what's the
morale from the story but maybe when
there's a good opportunity around you
don't miss it yeah look around
you know what else you can do so
maybe you can invent the new things to
work on and if you're doing it correctly
then it catches on so tell me uh
is behind so many different other
Vehicle Systems so we've seen a few
in Russell stock so there are no sense
of school systems
IPS
stabbing planes
I don't know if it was you who uh
formulas the highest calculus
I didn't promise it I just showed the
same
thing but we can fix history it doesn't
matter
okay so
yeah and come at work so I sometimes
think that a paper is interesting if a
Airbus asked a question if it was
answered or B if Michael wrote it okay
but here in both complexity we can see
that if somebody comes up with the right
question and actually the the community
takes interest and you know when I was
studying these things it never came up
to me that somebody had to invent it at
some point yeah it was just there and uh
you know part of life
so it's quite sober and to think that at
one point or another it wasn't in
existence
okay so we're inventing new areas you
cannot even go further like the work and
I'm sure in furnace and so on this is
perhaps even more impressive or I said
look left and right so this is really
broadening The Horizon
another thing is uh
well systematically studying an area
okay so we have several examples of
lifting uh tfnp
then
when you study the same area if you were
large enough extent you actually get
somewhere yeah that's maybe the one
thing that I did learn from Tony that's
the one thing I'm trying to practice
the other thing is trying to force
connection between areas so this uh we
already saw it in Russell's talk but the
state and p connection it actually
originates with the paper by Tony at all
so that's uh there are some tips of how
to do good research
yeah there are some other key tips that
I heard from Tony
so be bold okay so you choose what to
work on when I choose what to work and I
try to find the thing that I think that
I can do and nobody else can do but this
is not a good idea
what if you do you should look at the
questions that are actually interesting
in the community and and try to attack
them you know
it probably will succeed because nobody
else tries
I was suggesting to try to solve
feverses and P but there are enough
problems which are interesting and you
can actually make progress on
yeah what else
um
yes I like the atmosphere in University
of Toronto very much okay
that's very friendly
for the very cohesive group of graduate
students some of them are here
this is not what I encountered when I
started my own faculty job at the Techno
and this makes for a big difference it's
not funny it makes for a big difference
our graduations don't work together
by the fact that they hardly work
together
now why is that
it's a question of I know atmosphere
and this is something that they do in
ufd very well
okay and maybe it's it's also because of
the personalities involved okay so some
people are easier to work with
you know it's it's maybe hard to imagine
but mint only actually had a clash at
some point unless you remember and we
had this dramatic phone call when we
promised that if something bothers us
we'll talk it through
yeah I think for you we're all right now
there's no hard feelings right now
yeah since then there were some funny
stuff that happened with other people
like um an advisor who tells a question
to their graduate student and then
forget about it and then both of them
work in parallel and with the same
conclusion it can be very bad
but if you're very careful and you're in
good communication with uh with your
peers and your your students and
everything is fine
I think part of the success is this
question of personality and having peers
that you work with so
these are people who were at some point
your fellow graduate students or your
advisors your students it makes a big
difference so I suggest anybody to
Foster this kind of community
so I think back at my own
that's a long research life
you know I have a temporary friend and
then they go away
yeah I don't think it's funny it's just
a fact of life that's the way it is and
I think it's better if the people don't
go away
that's why I think I think it works
better
yeah so that was a bit about uh
Tony
I know I thought so I was planning for a
somewhat shorter talk
but even that went too fast like
everything I do
but I thought in the remaining time I
will tell you a bit about what I'm up to
okay because maybe you're interested to
know what Tony students do
okay so I just looked uh
I have uh three papers with Tony not
counting Journal versions
okay
that's your papers for my PHP and one
from this is a really fun semester we
had five years ago right here
yeah the first two are improved complex
here neglected to mention but actually I
was going through all the papers of Tony
that I know of and
you know almost all of them although
they're in in sort of different topics
there is this this thread that goes
through all of them and this is proof
complexity
yeah so this is like um
what you learn when you're young and it
just stays with you
so when I was introduced to perform next
year I thought oh it was it's very cool
it's a connection between logic and math
computer science
at some point I felt like all we were
doing is reading the Masters and trying
to comment on them and I didn't like it
but it seems that if you're doing it
correctly then you actually have really
new and fresh ideas and it can take you
really far
okay
so I've worked a bit on this topic and a
bit maybe on the very related topic of
computational complexity
but really even though tell me was my
official advisor also I had a shadow
advisor
so
even before I started my PhD I was
introduced to uh Edward friedwood and he
told me a lot I'm going to Toronto maybe
you'd like to join me so of course I
agreed and then one month before I got a
phone call look uh Yuval we're coming
back you do what you want
stay with me you can go there your
choice I think I made the right choice I
went to Toronto
anyway if there is one thing that goes
through much of my research it must be
what Friedberg does which is a Boolean
function analysis
yeah so that's what I aspire to do
in contrast maybe to uh what I suggested
shouldn't be done
instead of trying to find the core
questions that actually make a
difference
what I like doing is finding my own
questions that I care about but nobody
else should care about
all right so
in a sense that's what all of us in TCS
do okay so there's this cool revolution
around us right on this AI Revolution
and some people actually start working
on it you know even people like Tony and
Cynthia
you know there's this great scientific
question which is a
little pertinence to humanity and and
you know I don't think these people have
anything interesting to say but at least
they're trying
in a sense or if we're doing PCS then we
are saying okay we do what we think is
interesting to us
we okay so sometimes people think that
actually people should care and some
people just do it because they're
interested in it and maybe there's some
combination it depends on who you talk
to maybe
for whether you're trying to get money
or not
but yeah I still think that it's better
to work on something that people care
about now why don't they do it because
it it requires some
strong self-belief and uh
kind of uh what do you say
hey
of that sword okay that you're actually
going to to make it
okay so what I suggest to all of you is
to learn from Tony and have faith in
yourself and and work on the things that
matter
is the reason we do it in TCS and income
networks is because it has some
applications
right so even in this living work there
is an application to offer
analysis and maybe related areas and
definitely combinatorics and areas like
social Choice Theory but you can also
study it on its own and there are
questions which
should be more or less interesting
eventually if you're lucky then there
are some connections to other areas
okay so maybe
um
that's a bit uh technical also that you
benefit
a bit from the stock
so there's this um topic of complexity
matters of Boolean functions yeah maybe
some of you are just a sensitivity
conjecture extract through theorem
yeah people are very excited about this
approaches awkward for decades and now
it got solved it's actually useful for
anything
what do you think
what
because I looked so I couldn't find
anything I think people care about it
just because they care about it okay
deterministic algorithms
uh
okay so instead of proving the selector
and the microbes and other stuff and uh
yeah that's the stuff we do like we kind
of feel different so
anyway I was interested in extending
this to functions on other domains such
as the Symmetry group
okay I had my own reasons um this time
maybe they're even good reasons
but we actually managed to get something
from it okay
so we managed to solve some problem in
combinatorics using ideas that we
developed
now maybe the following itself is very
exciting but it does show that sometimes
you study the things that you see you
find interesting and they do find some
applications
okay so maybe that's um
I predicting what I said before
so I think it's more fruitful to look at
the central questions in the area and to
try to tackle them
yeah I now know why people said you
shouldn't talk too much about yourself
yeah you shouldn't say you shouldn't
talk about people unless you have
something nice to say
this is
something positive
yeah so sometimes there's a distance
between um
supervisor and student it's like uh your
kids or for those of us who are from
Israel
um intend to go to the Army and we have
our commander slash boss so
that's why it was a lot of fun when five
years ago there was this semester here a
little one semester and now all of us
were in equal footing
you know and um
that was like coming here to Berkeley
because of this feeling that there's you
know you land at SFO you see the
mountains the Hills
and suddenly feel relaxed you know the
weather is nice
company is great
so I had a lot of fun
it's hard to say whether it was actually
fulfilling scientifically
no to some extent yes but maybe you want
Good Hope for more
but I think part of being a researcher
it's it's um like a continuous mental
fight
these uh semesters these workshops
that's part of what gives you uh from
not losing the fight that's life okay
is that positive enough questions
[Applause]
tell us about your yeah you said that
you used the I think you're sensitivity
you generalize it to symmetric groups
then you said you were able to use those
approve
yeah so this reminds me of uh
where you explained this question and he
said oh and we're using it for something
but it's also interesting yes
Okay so
let's say that which is a symmetric
group of developments yeah and see in a
second
every
three
or at least
three points
so Alpha by one is equal to bet of i1
alpha of i t
aught
where all these indices are different
okay
now how big can such a family be
what do you think
that is intersecting how we can be it
depends on
D versus
um
T is small let's think of this concept
just finish the first two yes
um so are they they just have to agree
on some T points they don't have to be
the same key for every alphabet right so
like if you pick
uh oh I see so you really only expect
one point of agreement
for red and fermentation is true so uh
for all of us is
this means I learned something from it
and some other people
okay and moreover
if F equal to n minus t factorial
s
presentations
sending
one
another ID to JT
okay
so this only holds for a large enough
and and um one more stop to understand
what happens for all and
in general we have the what we think is
the best respectful for all energy
that is what you were trying to think
about
but nobody has any idea because the only
technology doesn't work
yeah okay but when k equals one then
everything is very simple this upper
bound is completely in our own material
recruiting risks
you can do it in various ways
okay
so now some people actually connected
they decided to try to extend this to
larger T okay
so for T equals two they could prove the
upper Bound for
Oh Aaron
but we can improve this uniqueness
is
but it's uh
and things are very exciting because
it's not a pretty hard to Extended to
all t
and without super specifically I don't
find I find it's limited
this is really exciting because we made
a first step to proving something really
interesting that this means there's a
really important open problem for all of
you to work up
[Applause]
all right yeah
questions
okay so let's take a break and after the
record at the end
yes
[Music]